desde alemania hasta japón la
solidaridad con el pueblo ucraniano
crece manifestantes en múnich pidieron
el cierre del consulado ruso formando
una cadena humana ante el edificio al
que le lanzaron pintura roja
ciudadanos ucranianos también se unieron
como aquí en la plaza de la república de
parís junto a los manifestantes
franceses
putin es un terrorista los rusos son
rehenes estamos aquí para ayudar para
hablar de ello
y todos los que etiquetan algo en
instagram dan un euro para ayudar a
ucrania están ayudando a mantener la paz
en el mundo si rusia solía ser más
grande pero tienen que superarlo los
países se han independizado desde
entonces las protestas son en contra de
la guerra pero también para aumentar la
presión sobre los países de la otan
europa tiene que luchar también por
ucrania no pueden utilizar a ucrania
como escudo
steinitz
tienen que protegernos y ayudarnos ahora
mismo estamos luchando por todos cerca
de okinawa los residentes hicieron sonar
la campana mundial de la paz
[Música]
las protestas continúan y muchos dicen
que volverán para hacer oír su voz hasta
que los ucranianos puedan vivir una vida
normal